welcome to this video I'm playing Alexia
from Germany let's see what we get are
these guys always playing this nye
Bishop f4 London system yeah maybe this
one tried to irritate him didn't work
this my queen b 6i think this is a quite
interesting line Wow it's not exactly
ambitious
yeah but still it's nothing special i
mean i am probably move up or something
but it's not not exactly a thrilling
position yeah it's fairly symmetrical I
only have I have my 22 moves up yeah
really we can really play Bishop f4 and
all the way back home okay you five then
yeah yeah playing riff open up the
position should should be at least okay
of course it's a nice lady porn but it's
it's it's an active position his bishop
is bed on d3 for the isolated pawn
hmm Wow yeah why why put this piece on
the edge not not clear to me 26th SF for
this is so embarrassing Quincy 7 this
may be runs into the should to Roxy one
ok seems that don't really have
something better than retreating all the
way
I think this is quite quite strange I
know but I hope that defies the key I
can play d4 next smooth to open up this
bishop he has no real way to prevent
that like d4a for ipv6 and when you form
I think we should see three I can take
win 8 5 at least six weird getting into
the sea farm but let's say let's see I
need to open this up I'm better
developed champ got more pieces into
play
I detected even consider this not sure
what if it is good or bad or anything
then I didn't consider the move at all
oh but I can take and take III right
this one's material ok taking both
bishops now d-3 ends and everything Jack
great so we'll just take it and what now
how to make life easy now Queen d3 may
be Queen d525 looks quite good attacking
g2
Luke a tube see one so I get a 3 as well
check
segen looks you on
and now I'm quickly on F to check oh I'm
just I only now recognized that this is
the wrong bishop but I don't have an
h-bomb I don't have an h-bomb so this
doesn't matter so much okay
check
need to be cautious sometimes this hook
look here look aged eight made or
something good could be on
if i play too no stab something I don't
think so cool I all have to have g5
check
check
I didn't really think about this one
this is annoying ah I thought King e4f
five
how would a shame how do i cabbages have
no Christ
ah Jesus time warning check what I'm
completely confused now he offered the
draw and what then I played a moose i
blundered the bishop board Jack Jack
what they don't I don't understand
anything you check check yeah the
position is even a draw I think so such
an unlucky configuration check
check check black one time what what a
nonsensical game what did I lose this
fish don't understand what's going on ah
what the heck happened here I could
completely confused here i played this
Mirage and then this I can just play
book p7e and then he resigns okay I took
here and then this is the problem I I
simply didn't see that move here I just
thought okay he goes he goes King to
what deck I thought he placed this and
then I played this whatever and it cover
yes nothing going on here just just to
win and I didn't really think about King
g3 yeah but look g7 a7 s winning the
bishop even at this is this is sick i
played this and blundered the bishop
amazing yeah i can play her in the
winningest as probably winning is out of
the question
and on the question anyway I need to do
this soon Jack Jack yeah and draw hey
what back yeah I completely forgot about
this King g3 stuff well I can play
anything here King h7 everything winds
but I thought okay let's do this in
active fashion but can just just
overlook that and then it confused me so
much that i blundered this Bishop
amazing would it be it game yeah well
thanks for watching